overwhelmed domestically and now overrun
internationally the bidens need to
appease their pay masters and it's all
coming into full view with their freak
out over lack of contact no callback
they were ghosted by China
first Deputy deputy secretary of state
Wendy Sherman lobbied against the uyghur
force labor prevention act in 2021 and
now she's blocking sanctions on CCP
officials and companies like Huawei why
well because she was eager to reschedule
the Tony blinken trip according to
Reuters sources this administration's
Outreach to the CCP has us on Klinger
watch
I gotta get out of here Pronto I got a
stage five Clinger I need more time did
you hear what I just said to you stage
five
Bloomberg reporting the White House has
proposed meetings and calls from the
lowest level all the way up to a
possible conversation between XI and
Biden
now I would say that all the begging
means we risk losing any leverage at all
we had with China but look we lost that
long ago the white Administration
doesn't want leverage on China they just
want president XI to be happy
or at least pretend to be happy
when Americans are angry with the
federal government they tell those
Americans just suffer deal with it when
President XI is angry wow they act like
eighth graders waiting to hear from
their Crush please call me back joining
me now Arkansas Senator Tom Cotton
Senator even Bloomberg had to kind of
scoff at this this loss of any leverage
that the administration may have had by
its persistent constant begging of China
for a meeting what about this
uh Laura I think you hit the nail on the
head it's a stage five cleaner alert
that's like an eighth grader chasing
after a crush it's pathetic and
embarrassing and it does nothing but
emboldened Chinese Communists when they
think that Joe Biden and all of his
administration is willing to trade away
all of these concrete needful actions
for our national security just for a
phone call or for a meeting remember it
goes back to the very beginning of our
Administration when Tony blinken and
Jake Sullivan went to Alaska and met
with their Chinese counterparts and got
berated with BLM left-wing talking
points and just took it or look back to
the balloon incident itself which
apparently was part of the reason why
the state department canceled all of
these needful sanctions remember we knew
about that balloon I should say the bite
Administration knew Congress didn't days
before it was revealed and it was only
revealed when some ranchers and a
photographer in Montana discovered it
why the delay because they were trying
to preserve Tony blinken's trip to China
just a couple days later look there's
nothing wrong with sitting down with
your adversaries Ronald Reagan did it a
lot with Mike Mikhail Gorbachev in his
second term once he had established the
strength and credibility to make it
clear that we expected outcomes from
those talks not just sitting down to
talk for the sake of talking right
well as I noted in the open Senator
Wendy Sherman was the one who lobbied
against protecting the uyghurs that
legislation that initiative to to
actually we would we would effectively
be putting our stamp on this idea of not
allowing the continued persecution of
them she didn't want that now she's the
lead
in the in any conversation with China
what does that tell China
well that's a very alarming report
remember Wendy Sherman is also someone
who's been in Democratic foreign policy
failures going back to the North Korea
nuclear talks in the mid-1990s or the
Iran nuclear deal under President Obama
if she's in charge now of China policy
in the state department that's very
alarming uh she's as you said was
lobbying against sanctions for China
using slave labor to try to import Goods
into America
putting sanctions on Huawei in which
we're in a steep competition around the
world to try to win the 5G race it's
very worrying if Wendy Sherman has been
given a free hand inside the state
department to address our China policy
yeah it makes China happy reports
tonight that she'll be leaving the
administration soon we'll see if that
actually transpires Senator thank you so
much hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else